else wait can I can I do a thing on the
average thing real quick because we we
were talking about that for real fine
okay so you can add off to you one bit I
was gonna say well it's not my show so
whatever yeah whatever's allowed okay so
what the reason why when somebody calls
somebody average that's usually
perceived to be an insult right I think
we we hear it that way we give it that
way nobody's ever told somebody that
there's their average is like a nice
thing to say to somebody now we can say
that like oh well average is most people
are average kind of but also not really
right if you look at like an average
person like an average person has 1.9
legs because some people are missing
legs but no human has 1.9 legs you have
two or one right when we look at who we
are as people there are some things that
we excel at and there are some things
that we don't do anything yet so I think
that's why we never feel average right
because we're above average hopefully at
whatever our competency is in So when
you say that somebody's average is
always going to be perceived as an
insult so I'm sure that uh Camilla or
anybody else you guys all had crazy
degree you guys are all more educated
than I am right I'm sure that on a whole
you might be an average person but
you're not going to perceive yourself
that way because you push yourself
forward in some areas that make you not
average and hopefully you're looking for
other people to plug into that those
above average
it can be an average I just want to say
it's not about even my degree you know
it's not about my masters it's about
what I've overcome and achieved in this
life that makes me a Survivor and above
average I have been homeless on the
street and I'm sitting here today and
not representing that my struggle My
Success makes me above average and
nobody can't tell me that I'm not
because if that's what I need to tell
myself to get up in the morning and do
my [__] that's what's gonna have to
happen okay
hold on bro no listen listen listen
no no it's not yourself shut up shut up
you disrespecting me I'm I've got a
reason don't talk to me like that bro
okay
stop stop stop stop I just told you to
stop I just thought I just told you to
stop talking guys guys I was gonna give
you a chance but you can't you can't
come on Wow 30 30 seconds ago 30 seconds
and then you
yeah 30 seconds just can't stop talking
okay anyway I can't remember she just
freed me off okay remember okay
um it was just so funny okay okay
guys you guys guys guys no listen listen
listen listen guys guys
guys
they might the mics are off now guys
guys guys guys guys
yo yo yo all right all right guys okay
okay all right thank you you're the
first rule of the podcast don't
interrupt the host there we're not going
to tolerate that no more if that happens
you gotta go thank you
yeah are we all cool with that okay all
right cool thank you I know I know
disrespectful stuff either thank you
okay wait wait no okay no no no no no no
stop okay thank you
um we're gonna go on to the next
question all right all right so I'm
gonna leave okay
this might be your platform but respect
okay okay goodbye go go go okay because
[Music]
don't call me bro I don't need you so
that's what you have to say that's what
we have to say
I'm just embarrassing yourself
I know you know something right do you
know something like excuse me excuse me
excuse me what's your name hello young
lady what's your name T do you know what
I'm gonna do for the first time ever I'm
gonna [__] follow you
see you later
okay okay look at look at look at look
at your your issue your issue stop
you're doing it again okay oh my God
oh
my God
you're lucky I'll smoke you myself
[Music]
used to bro
let's go
you need something
you you keep over to us get get get out
get out get out get out get out
how many puppies do oh my God get out
get out
get the get the [__] up get the [__] out
of my apartment get out oh my God oh my
god oh
my God
okay hold on can I just for my own
safety who are we allowed to call for
out here and who are we not allowed to
call bro I just want to know get the
[__] out lock the blessing go lock the
other side too last thing lock the [__]
yeah the only reason was because she
kept interrupting me Jesus Christ
look it I don't oh my God
what can you go check just go go double
check go
okay
yeah but she's saying I was
disrespectful to how
yeah okay okay
you kept going okay guys guys guys guys
guys guys okay
she's gonna be like waiting outside
you know it's crazy we're supposed to
have security
tonight and it didn't I was like
nah that's scary I'm sorry I'm I was
scared yeah the only reason I was gonna
let her talk is the crazy thing but she
kept interrupting me and I was just like
if you're gonna keep interrupting me you
have to go like I don't
is the same one in this podcast
okay um I can't believe Auntie Jenny was
worse than me just saying okay hold on
we shouldn't shut down anybody I'm not
I'm not trying to be fair okay I didn't
think anyone was that crazy until she
started yeah okay my next question
I actually didn't think it was that bad
but I guess I just want to know why
she's so mad that cooler broke when I
cool everyone broke if it's like it's
just a respect thing man it's like
you're Elders like I just would never I
didn't know yeah yeah it's just like I
just wouldn't call people that but I
don't think
I don't think you meant it like that no
I I think they were already upset and
then him saying bro was just like a
Timber but if they were cool and they
were calling each other bro I think they
would care it doesn't matter
yeah and I think it's because you kept
antagonizing the situation she was like
don't call me bro you're like all right
bro
what I'm speaking like it's just my
vernacular that's just how I speak in it
like so I'm not even thinking like oh
yeah I'm trying to push her buttons like
all my thing was is that let me say
something because at this point I've
said the least out of everybody a few
moments later I was going to close out
the show so thank you guys all for
coming
um Annie hey we made it look who's left
[Music]
we made it
so I want to I want to clearly can't
believe that happened I want to point
out why you say TV you said Africa is
the best but Nigeria is the best I'm
Nigerian oh I mean I think she was ready
why would you say you want to go to
South Africa so bad because the top
producers South African that's the
reason I mean I think this podcast
why are you the worst and that's why
it's
zimbabweight hey give me some give me
some white power
well I just said that because I just
felt like some type of way of the way
she she addressed the whole um Caribbean
and you're African and I'm gonna speak
like I just kind of it just rubbed me
the wrong way like it's not that deep
like you know what I'm saying I don't
really understand why she left a lot to
Africans though they think that they're
better than Africans because I'm very
much but there's a lot of tension in
that respect but I just feel like like
obviously I like bro at the end of the
day if you're really gonna take that as
like oh yeah I'm gonna leave I mean
that's up to you in it and I think and
and anyone watching anyone that's ever
watched a video with me will I do the
podcast with the girls I call everyone
bro everybody bro it's not now the um
especially being disrespectful to anyone
I don't think you I think I don't think
you meant it like that and I I don't
know we're just gonna move on
okay so we're going to close out the
show so any final thoughts please 30
seconds or less
um and you can plug in your social media
where they can find you whatever so
starting here and then go around oh
final thoughts no can we go start on
this side I need to talk about it fine
uh Michael do you want to start
all right we got to me
no listen King rich is on YouTube go
check out my channel uh we got podcasts
over there over there we've got uh shows
podcasts reaction videos everything
um yeah go check out the channel and
what's my final thoughts uh
yeah maybe I should stop calling people
bro but you know it's just the way I
speak it's not on me trying to
especially be disrespectful if you take
it disrespectfully you know you know
sorry in it like but that's just how I
speak in it don't take it as a deep
thing I don't think I deserve to get
sliced up for it but you know that's
what some people think but it's cool in
it good luck on the streets tonight yeah
yeah
well done I'm proud of you thank you
okay Destiny yeah uh Big Ups to Pearl
for hosting this great show uh you can
find me at youtube.com Destiny that's
all I got
um Pearl stop saying Esther you need to
listen it actually is quite dishes
everything's disrespectful these days
but it is
disrespectful to not to over talk a host
on someone else oh oh purple I'm talking
I'm talking you need to listen because
you talk I'm talking it's my time it's
my time to talk how does that feel you
talk the whole Esther how does that feel
okay
I'll give you no time I'm gonna give you
no time all right your turn go go your
turn your turn okay then all right
maybe we didn't all survive yeah
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out faster Esther then get out
come here then ask her ask her I don't
care Esther Esther Esther Esther I'm not
gonna get it
looking
because because after because you were
being rude Esther go get then get out
get the Esther Esther Esther get Esther
Esther get out Esther Esther get out get
out of my get out of my apartment get
out no get out no get out get out I'm
not gonna do that
anyways faster no your mic is muted get
the [__] out of my apartment get out get
out you're gonna be disrespectful the
whole goddamn show get out yeah I'll
call security I'll literally call
security that's very rude no can you
call security no no because you are
being rude because you are over talking
me call security get her out
foreign
anyway so you guys can follow me at
Sophie Joy X on Instagram I'm going to
be doing a lot more podcasts and
political uh Media stuff and yeah I hope
to
I this is a lot of fun and yeah can't
wait to do more
oh my God
yeah
no I wanna that's fine I wanna no
because it's not fair I'm so sorry you
don't invite me into your house and then
try to disrespect me by kicking me out I
am sorry I'm going to have my voice no
if we're going to be here security we're
all gonna talk because we're not gonna
do that that is very disrespectful and
that no that is that you can you can put
it no that's the ultimate disrespect how
dare you invite me to your husband and
try to kick me out because I'm trying to
tell you how I feel about how you're
treating me you're just embarring
[Music]
but can I just say one last thing yeah
headphones headphones
I don't know why I did that for myself I
don't know why I even came I guess
foreign
it's not easy yeah so just know what it
is and yeah go subscribe to my channel
bro yeah this happens a lot on my
channel as well yeah even more so go
subscribe King riches right now yeah go
subscribe to my Channel right now yeah
if you like drama like this go subscribe
to my Channel right now I feel like I
won The Hunger Games huh yeah well hold
on we just said that with four of us
here okay
I'm the last standing girl you know
what's crazy this is I swear to God this
has never happened in my year of shows
anyways
um okay guys it was a lot of fun I loved
it okay guys um thank you for watching
this this [__] show
these shoes Matt uh this is your first
show coming back yeah that is Matt thank
you for watching this [__] show we love
this city thank you to Destiny for
coming on yes
enjoying this you know
um thank you guys for coming I
appreciate it I appreciate being able to
have these conversations guys make sure
you like the video I'd say respectfully
disagree but someone threatened me yeah
like I can't even say that um okay like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel also um guys follow my
Instagram just pearly things one